The Witcher 3 hearts of stone is that
once a horror story of romance a
character study and a classic fairy tale
and somehow these disparate parts mesh
to form a cohesive whole
this is CD Projekt RED first paid
expansion for it's masterful RPG and it
fits seamlessly into gerelds narrative
although it's meant for late-game
characters around level 30 it's
available at any point in your
playthrough and like many experiences in
The Witcher 3 the expansions main draw
as it's twisting storylines and vivid
characters it's difficult to talk about
these elements without ruining the
experience as a whole CD Projekt RED
presents its own dark take on weddings
haunted houses and the story of the
prince and the Frog quest never resolved
how I expected them to and seldom how I
hope hearts of stone runs the gamut of
fantasy tropes but subverts everyone
it's this willingness to take successful
risks that sets these quests and the
story they compose apart many of these
storylines trace back to one man gone
taro dim Geralt calls in the merchant of
mirrors others know him as the man of
glass he's a character who makes you
feel uneasy with a glance and even when
you seem relaxed I always had my thumb
hovering over the attack button but
there are good people in the northern
kingdoms too however few and far between
hearts of stone reintroduces Shawnee the
medic from oxenfurt who reprises her
role from the original witcher she's my
favorite character here and maybe in all
of the witcher 3
she's equal parts charming caring and
clever in fact Shani's much smarter than
Geralt your responses have a time limit
much more frequently when speaking with
her she's quick-witted but only gives
that away the more time you spend with
her and if you don't remember or weren't
aware of the history that garel and her
share from the earlier games it doesn't
matter
CD Projekt RED conveys this with expert
dialogue and subtle visual cues it's not
often you can read into animated
characters body language but here
Shaunie's lingering glances and Geralt
sluzer gestures tell a story in
themselves once again CD Projekt RED
excels at capturing the details between
these living stories and fluid
narratives are engrossing quests I
planned a heist recruited team members
and cringed as my plan fell apart I also
attended a wedding straight out of a
sitcom complete with praiseworthy comedy
and awkward scenarios
it's almost midnight time for the
captain wait I'm not done oh yes you are
even in the absence of combat and
supernatural catastrophes hearts of
stone pulled me through with expert
pacing well for the most part at least
CD Projekt implemented several minigames
throughout this expansion most of which
are tracking sections Geralt Witcher
senses usually lead you only a few feet
away to a break of a wall or hidden
object that seemed place just for the
sake of it there's also an infuriating
section that places you in a muddy pen
as you try to herd pigs toward their
respective troughs the activity alone
breaks the overall immersion but Geralt
wide turns double the annoyance factor
in the end these activities are
negligible in the grand scheme of things
when combat does rear its head there are
unique enemies and tenacious boss
battles to keep the dynamism alive in
fact I saw three such enemies within the
first two hours of hearts of stone I
fought a mage a headless swordsman and a
hideous beast much largely garel with
more complex attack patterns and many of
the northern kingdoms other denizens
there's this one enemy later on in a
graveyard outside an abandoned Manor
whose character design echoes the
horrors of Pan's Labyrinth it's
grotesque it's terrifying stabilities
make for one of the more grueling
encounters I faced as Jerrold defeating
that thing was both a triumph and a
relief for all of its storylines and all
of its varied combat hearts of stone
houses deeper themes ideas of regret
apathy death and the passage of time
pervade every characters motivations
this thematic pulse elevates an already
great batch of content parts of stone
feels just as much a part of the
narrative as any of the main games quest
lines but it also stands on its own as a
memorable adventure it may have its
negative moments and the pacing may be
broken at certain intervals but The
Witcher 3 is first paid expansion it's
well worth the return to the northern
kingdoms
let's scooch along kitty this place
what's that
that ticking
you